hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on for honor again today
we're gonna be checking out the new
effect that has just released with the
update that came out today it is this
arcade specific effect all you have to
do go to arcade mode click on weekly
quest you will have one weekly quest to
do I believe it's you know one question
multiple chapters within it and stuff
like that so let's see we have to do
here
the recommended gear score is 162 so
that means I have to have some type of
high level character so most likely
gladiator is gonna be the one for this
so we're gonna probably hop in there's
four chapters hopefully these aren't too
long these are the legendary quest
remember so these may be a little bit on
the tough side but we'll see how these
matches go so far
hey guys real quick it's editing ginger
here you'll notice because I have the
black and white in the background that's
me I am from the future I just want to
let you know that half of these will be
alone half of these will be with a
teammate which I'll note which I'll
explain in a second basically I went
through half of them couldn't beat the
third in the fourth one so I ended up
actually getting a teammate and we ran
through it together his name is Pokemon
key 14 you guys might know him as my
moderator in the streams and all I ask
you do you guys to do is just go follow
his twitch channel it's the only thing
I'd rather shout out for him and that's
the only thing he recommended me to do
today guys go in the description check
his check his twitch out follow him he
plays a lot of games for tonight's
asin's Creed lots of for honor as well
in there as well so if you guys wanted
to chill out watch his stream like I
said you could check that out and let's
go with this video
all right so that's the end of that one
that sort of a tough I didn't talk
thought that entire thing because I was
worried the shaman was gonna kill me I
did a lot of student mistakes there I
[Music]
jesus [ __ ] christ what the [ __ ] why
did it a lot gonna hurt ah [ __ ] alright
okay okay alright well Kensei kind of
smacked me
I [ __ ] died dude can't say did a sun
block of one I got I got a Bible
remarkable hi Deborah Cox I wondered you
I want the probably guard break you hole
go girl [ __ ] god dude let's go oh oh
I hate this class dude dude we have oh
my god we have to kill them all at the
same time
oh my god
Oh interesting
this is anything isn't it I lose my mind
I'd actually kill myself if I don't I
feel like this should definitely zone
his best zone his best let's go let's go
let's go the Saudis to guided don't even
bother what the [ __ ] oh my god dude what
do you mean oh [ __ ] dude let's go this
[ __ ] looks sick oh this is definitely
some heat so yeah guys that was the
gameplay of the effect the whole thing
was like an hour and a half and I cut
that down to probably what four or five
minutes I'm not entirely sure how long
that was but yeah there was times where
we got really really close and died and
it was really depressing so I'm finally
glad we got that done I will show the
effect one more time the game would
allow me to go to the hero menu for once
yeah no I was it's definitely a hard
cost it's not too hard there's a few
strats that you can use but I only got
it for the emotes which honestly I think
is perfect because I don't really think
I need it for anything else don't really
care about the execution I just think
that this is perfect the way that it is
so yeah we're gonna happen to just do
one quick duel probably not maybe one or
two duels we'll see how that goes
and then just show it off a bit well and
for the match we have a Shaolin now he's
not rep one I believe he's level 11 so
but still he's very new to the character
but you know a decent level you know
that gives him a little bit of
experience but in his shelwyn he's got
mad lights so I'm not gonna give this
guy and you know some leeway never know
oh and he's back perfect
welcome sir no problem my guy
nice house like that was an interesting
fight I'm uh I've just been a little
quiet because I'm trying to concentrate
against this Sheldon he's very difficult
not like the guy playing a Sheldon but a
Shaolin in general is a very difficult
character personally for me to fight
against I am taking my time just trying
to learn the moveset I'm still not good
at parrying Shaolin lights I'm slowly
getting there with time but it is
becoming a little bit of a hassle
I missed that easy heavy
you are the saucy deflect that almost
hit me - they'll bleed out that was good
oh I forgot the snowball I forgot those
the combat emotes as well nice that's
cool I like dude this is actually really
sick I could wait you forgot that the
combat emotes counted for this as well I
like this see we got nice little yellow
and red going on there what's the emote
spam looking like just a little bit of a
red glow nothing too saucy it's a shame
well he dodged he knew it was coming but
he dodged a little bit late there was
that streak you might have saw my
screenshot or a bit that's because he
dodged as I swung so or as I did the
move so he knew the timing he was just a
little bit late quick three one that's
gonna little law a little bit confused
there I was uh I was definitely a little
bit scared once my health is getting low
that I didn't want to lose that fight
you know quick three one so not too bad
they're getting a little bit better
again Shaolin learning some of the
combos that a lot of people seem to use
but the light attacks are still a bit of
a problem for me so hopefully we'll get
that with uh
what some within you know in due time
all eventually get the timing suppose
yeah guys it's gonna be the end of it
hope you guys did enjoy like I said just
want to show off the arcade effect it's
really cool maybe we'll get a new one
next week or maybe this is going to be
the same thing I'm not entirely sure
with the whole dealio with this is maybe
next week like I said we might get an
entirely new effect or it might just be
the same effect but we get more chances
at it because if you do it one time it's
guaranteed what if you do it any other
time after your first attempt is
completed then it's a chance so if I
were to attempt this again and I win I
may or may not get this the next time
and it's also for the character that you
play it with so definitely keep that in
mind as well
want to get her a specific character hey
guys look the VP doing Joseph's Cobra
for new cover the informational site of
foreigner that being balanced changes
here or updates patch notes leaks all
that good stuff here know what's going
on that's some gladiator gameplay
showing off some stuff like this my two
most recent videos would be on-screen in
a bit if you guys do want to check that
out with that guy said yesterday thank
you for watching the video
[Music]
[Music]
you